what the [ __ ] are we doing today you're
having me drink water like hydrogen and
oxygen the consistency it looks like
water think I'm mentally like bodily
kind of taste - it tastes like water
since it just makes me thirsty or I'm
gonna say it expensive and I think it's
cheap will I drink this yes this is the
life source that runs this planet missus
- sir they charge you so much it is such
a ripoff it's made by the biggest soda
company in the world there's something
evil about that right like I'm not crazy
the way it splashes within reminds me of
water
I like this water this just it tastes
like water which is what I want from my
water expensive like spa water
I bet this one's expensive now that I'm
talking all this cuz I'm about it
this is peachy I love it
this is what I'm talking about this is
just a normal stuff Harrow head its
water dummy
just drink it is that water I don't have
any problems with it this is like your
older brothers holding your head
underwater in a pool and you take just
like one little gasp of air desperately
but all you get is chlorine OOP I don't
like the fun it's people are filming
dumb expensive water that they like
throw some th [ __ ] in delish
Iceland pure spring water with a pH of
8.88 added pH guys my water palette is
pretty on point right
so I know it's not cheap because there's
no metal aftertaste top of the tastes
refreshing end of the taste little tap
watery Fiji maybe I don't know something
about it it tastes like it seems some
pipes cheap you would still drink it but
you have more fun spraying it on your
lawn I would say like 115 suck it BTG
that's upsetting cuz it looks so pretty
oh this one look fancy there's some
fancy water oh my god oh my god I just
know from the smell like I don't you
need to taste this thing that's tap
water this is pool water
aka Los Angeles tap water because
everyone knows I like water is
disgusting there's somebody sells this
they should be ashamed I now want to go
back and revise all my other answers
that was like there's not difference
with water no there's a difference this
is not good water yeah no you should not
pay more for water if you're paying for
like this designer brand bottle just
know what you're paying for is that
fancy cool-looking design no one has any
right to be snobbish about water it is
one of the most essential things in the
world we are lucky to have it just drink
it